while we are here tonight looking ahead
to 2022 we also understand that 2021 has
been tough for a lot of people yeah it
has nikki that's why we are partnering
with the super bowl of caring to raise
money to help feed people in need here
now is the executive director of super
bowl of caring allison reese now tell us
what a difference even a small donation
can make oh absolutely a small donation
of just one dollar can make three meals
and so if you give
you know 25 that's 75 meals it adds up
very quickly and how do people also know
that when they make a donation that that
money is going to go to people in their
community their local community right
well that is the beauty of the tackle
hunger map when you go to the map you
find locations that are feeding people
right now
in their community wherever they are
around the country and they can donate
directly to that charity and that money
will be going directly to that through
super bullet carrying we make sure that
that money gets there incredible i love
that we're putting out the positive vibe
it's all about helping people out in
2022 showing empathy and i just have to
say thank you so much for stopping by we
really really appreciate it thank you
allison yes well thank you helping to
help us to tackle hunger that's
incredibly important our food pantries
are doing yeoman's work this year and we
need to keep that up yes we do yes we do
happy new year happy new year to you
thanks for joining us all right we want
to do our part and let's get this
started off right with a donation from
our friends at nexstar
hi i'm lisa howefield vice president and
general manager of klas in las vegas
after a tough couple of years it's
important for us to find a way to give
back so on behalf of nexstar i'm honored
to present this donation of ten thousand
dollars from the next star media
charitable foundation happy new year
if you want to help it's actually very
easy you can scan the qr code on your
screen you can text nye donate to
26989 or you can call
1-800-358-soup we have people from the
radial phone bank standing by to take
your calls tonight is a big night of
celebration